and so what's your connection tonight
you were in the film and what made you
say yes to the role
I made it's an amazing script and I I
would never turn it down it was amazing
and the experience was even better than
the scripts I guess it was just one of
these things that made it a incredible
experience working in such a group like
such a great group with such amazing
actors in terms of Anarchy how far would
you go for a role in terms of what would
you do to obtain information or get
yourself seen from a casting director
what type of extreme measures would you
take I mean I'm not very extreme I I am
a little more on the flip side you know
why I want to go in there and do the
best that I can do and if that's right
that's right